[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIA GARCIA PUYOL: Hello,
everybody and thanks
for joining our session.
My name is Maria
Garcia Puyol, and I'm
a software engineer
on the Android
Location and Context team.
And I'm also one of the
co-founders of the Android
Emergency Location
Service, which
helps find wireless
emergency callers faster.
Now, by a show of hands,
who in the audience,
like me, has ever dialed 9-1-1
or any other emergency number
with their smartphone?
So I can see a few.
Let me share my
story of the one time
I dialed 9-1-1, which is
one of the reasons why
we started this project
in the first place.
In 2014-- right after I
had just joined Google--
I bought my first car.
And this is me, all
happy on that night.
About 10 minutes after
leaving the dealership,
I encountered one of the
scariest moments of my life.
Suddenly, out of the
blue, out of nowhere,
there was a woman standing
in the middle of the highway.
I had to very quickly
swerve to avoid hitting her,
and luckily I didn't.
Immediately after,
I took my phone
and dialed 9-1-1, the emergency
number in the United States.
And after explaining what
I had just witnessed,
the first question they asked
me was, where's your emergency?
And they ask you
this because to be
able to send your
help right away,
they need to know
your precise location.
But today, over 80%
of emergency calls
are dialed with smartphones.
In contrary to public
belief, first responders
may have a really hard
time locating you.
This is because they rely
on very inaccurate location
information, as my
colleague, Soonil, will
explain in a moment.
Now back to my story.
I was new to the area--
I had just moved to the Bay
Area to work at Google--
and I didn't know where I was.
Everything that
I was able to say
was, I'm driving on some
highway in Mountain View.
Luckily for us,
other 9-1-1 callers
had reported the
lady on the road,
and they were able
to dispatch help.
But finding emergency
callers may not
be as easy in many
other situations.
The irony about this, is that we
rely on very accurate location
information for pretty much
everything in our lives.
Today, you can get a pizza
delivered to your door
from a nearby restaurant.
You can upload a picture with
the right, precise location
on social media.
And you can even get
a date around you.
But, somehow, that accurate
location that you see on Google
Maps cannot be shared
with first responders,
so that they can find
you during an emergency.
So even though you see the blue
dot that you're so used to,
and that you rely on for
pretty much everything,
nowadays, our first
responders may not
be able to say where you're
calling from in a big city.
I had just joined the
Android Location team.
So some colleagues
and I sat down,
and wonder if
there was something
we could do to help fix this.
It boiled down to
one single question.
What if your mobile phone
could send its precise location
to first responders
automatically.
By precise location, again,
I mean that accurate blue dot
that you see on Google Maps.
We got very excited
about this possibility.
And a small team of
us started to work
on this as a 20% project.
So we spent 20% of our time--
roughly, one day a week--
at Google working on
the first prototype.
And we focused on three
basic founding principles.
The first of them was that we
wanted to make it automatically
available everywhere.
So we decided to ship the
Android Emergency Location
Service as part of Google
Play services, which
is available on almost every
Android device out there,
and is updated regularly.
And that way users don't need
to download an emergency app,
you just need to download the
emergency number normally.
We wanted to protect
the user's privacy.
And so the location is
computed on the device,
on your mobile phone, and
sent directly from your phone
to first responders.
And only during emergencies.
And our main goal was to improve
the state of emergency services
around the world,
and help save lives
by providing more accurate,
but also, faster locations.
The project became the Android
Emergency Location Service,
or ELS.
And it started to get deployed
in some countries in 2016,
just two years later.
Let me share with you one of the
most incredible examples of how
this technology is
helping save lives today.
It took place in
Austria last year.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
[GROANING]
[PHONE DIALING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- Hello?
Hello?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[HELICOPTER HOVERING]
[INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
MARIA GARCIA PUYOL: Cool.
I'm going to hand it
over to my colleague,
Soonil, who's going to explain
what the state of emergency
location was when we
started the project,
and why it would have
been very hard to find
the protagonist of our video.
SOONIL NAGARKAR: Thanks, Maria.
So I'm Soonil, I'm
the tech lead for ELS,
and great to be here
with all you guys today.
Now we've all seen
the Hollywood movies,
or even TV shows, where as
soon as there's a problem,
we can see a call taker with
a high tech screen tracking
the caller's location, down
to the exact room they're in.
The reality, not quite as
glamorous, unfortunately.
So how is it possible
that Google Maps
can know exactly where you
are, but a 911 call may not?
So we're going to start with
a quick, non-comprehensive
overview of how the
9-1-1 system actually
works in the United
States, and what
can go wrong along the way.
So E911, Enhanced
911, is a system
in use in most of the US.
Now, Enhanced 911
specifically refers
to the ability to get location
data alongside a call.
In the US, 9-1-1 didn't
exist until the late '60s.
And the vast majority of what
is now called the E911 system
was developed in the '70s,
when the only type of phone
was a landline.
E911 was, of course, a huge
advancement at the time.
Before that, there
was just a call.
There was no location
information, whatsoever.
Now, some quick
pieces of trivia.
That red phone you see up
there is the actual phone
that the first 9-1-1
call was placed on.
And below that, a real picture
of one of the first call
centers ever built. Pretty
high tech for the time, right?
All right, so this system
was designed in the '70s,
but it hasn't really changed
that much since then.
And even today,
if you visit a 911
call center, much of the data--
even though it
might be presented
on modern LCD screens--
is likely delivered
via serial cables.
Let's take a look
at how this aging
system works behind the scenes
in order to get location.
The first thing that
we want to know about
is called the ALI, or the
Automatic Location Information
Database.
The ALI is essentially
just a big look-up table.
You get phone
numbers and one end,
street addresses out the other.
This makes sense
with landline phones.
Your kitchen
landline phone is not
going to be changing street
addresses very often.
But as mobile
phones came around,
the ALI had to be retrofitted.
Support for latitude and
longitude coordinates
was added.
Carriers had to be able
to push cell or GPS
location into this database.
So we take a look at this
real ALI record on the left,
there's a couple of
things to notice.
First of all, this
is a recent record.
This is from 2018.
Things still work
just like this today.
The maximum record size
here, is 512 bytes.
That's all the information
we have to work with, here.
And in many call
centers, those 512 bytes
are delivered over a
1,200 bps serial link.
Now, to do the
math quickly, that
means it takes 4.2
seconds just to download
this tiny amount of
information, and get
that in front of a call taker.
Now, some other
things to look at.
First of all, we
have the address.
You can see, here, this is
a call 87 Terrace Street
in Roxbury, Massachusetts.
We also have some latitude
and longitude information.
Kind of also buried in there
is accuracy and confidence
information that goes with it.
Now I was curious
about this address.
So I decided to take a look
at this on Google Street View.
Here's what we turned up.
This is a cell phone tower.
The real call was pinging
off the cell phone tower
that, I bet, that
whoever was calling
was not located anywhere
near this address.
And not anywhere near the
latitude and longitude
coordinates.
So that's one problem
with the E911 system.
But there's another problem
that better location
could help solve.
And that is called routing.
Now in the US, there are
6,000 call centers that
handle emergency calls alone.
And whenever you call 9-1-1
a decision has to be made,
which call center is
going to answer that call.
Usually this is done
based on the cell tower
you're connected to.
It's pretty straightforward,
usually works.
But there can be problems.
Cell towers often overlap
their range substantially.
The jurisdictions
that they serve
can overlap substantially.
All of these complications
mean that calls can easily
go to the wrong place.
And when that happens,
the answering call center
has to manually transfer
the call to the right place.
And that incorrect routing
eats precious time out
of every emergency call.
To give you a quick
example, it used
to be the case that here, in
California, any emergency calls
near highways were routed to
the California Highway Patrol,
even if the call had nothing
to do with the highway.
And the CHP call center was
responsible for triaging
that call, and
then redirecting it
to local agencies
as appropriate.
Now, one study in
Sacramento found
that this led to an average
delay of almost 60 seconds
just to transfer that
call from the CHP
to the Sacramento
Police Department.
Now, a 60 second delay
on every emergency call,
that really starts to add up.
So if ELS tell us
is able to deliver
highly accurate location
before the call starts--
or even in the first couple
seconds of the call--
then we can right place
immediately, instead
of routing it simply
based on the cell tower.
So at this point, we've
covered some background on E911
in the US, but we
haven't really talked
about the rest of the world.
Historically, there have
only been four countries
that mandate GPS as part
of their emergency systems,
and that have E911
systems similar to the US.
As you can see on the
map, Canada, the United
States, South Korea, and Japan.
For much of the
rest of the world,
Emergency Location is broken.
It either doesn't
exist, or is only
supported by cell tower
location technology, which
is notoriously inaccurate.
Now, this is the problem
we wanted to help fix.
And we designed the Android
Emergency Location System
to provide accurate and
quick fuse locations
to every country, as we saw in
the video from Austria earlier.
So, at this point, we've
covered some of the problems
that we want to solve.
ELS was designed
to bridge this gap,
providing Androids
quick and accurate
Fused Location
directly to emergency
services as a supplement
to existing E911 Location.
And to be integrated with
next generation 9-1-1 systems.
So let's talk about ELS
itself, and let's start
with a high level overview
of how our service works.
We can break this flow down
into four discrete steps.
First, of course,
the user has to call
or text 9-1-1, or other
emergency numbers such as 1-1-2
internationally, and so forth.
As soon as that call is made,
we start computing the location
on the device.
Once we get the
location, the next step
is to send that directly
from the device to emergency
partners.
And it's direct,
and that it does not
travel through Google servers.
It is then, the
partners responsibility
to send that location
on to the call center,
and to make sure
that it gets in front
of the call taker, who can use
that location on their call.
So the left side
of this is broadly
Google's responsibility.
And the right side is broadly
our partners responsibility.
Which brings us
to the next point,
what exactly is a partner?
So generally, we work with
three types of partners.
There are government agencies.
There are carriers
and operators.
And third party emergency
services companies.
So with over 6,000 call
centers in the US alone,
we rely on our partners-- and
their public safety expertise--
to get this location delivered
exactly where it needs to go.
So there is the overall flow.
How do we configuring
control this?
Well, Google administers this
on behalf of our partners.
And we have an incredibly
flexible configuration system
that supports all
kinds of things.
I'll touch on just a couple.
We support arbitrary
geographic polygons.
This lets us control
our activations
at a county level,
or a state level,
rather than just at
the country level.
It lets us touch on all sorts
of different jurisdictions.
We can use the country code and
network code from cell towers
to help base our logic, based
on the country and carrier
that this call is coming from.
And, of course, we
support location updates
for the entire duration
of the emergency call,
instead of just a single update.
So somebody made a 9-1-1 call.
We get the location.
Now, we need to send it.
How do we do that?
At the moment, we
use two methods.
Either an HTTPS
message or SMS message.
We're going to examine
both, but let's start
by examining the SMS message
in a little more detail.
Now, when we first started
thinking about ELS,
it happened that British
Telecom in the UK
had proposed a new standard
for location over SMS messages.
This was called the Advanced
Mobile Location format, or AML.
We adopted AML, and it's now
common everywhere in Europe.
There was one other
thing we had to think of.
We originally
started experimenting
using normal text messages,
the kind you might
send to your friend every day.
But there's one problem.
There's no way to
keep this from being
exposed in the user's
outbox, and this
presents a privacy concern.
Now, if you've ever called
9-1-1 from your Android device--
and it sounds like a
lot of you had to--
you may have noticed that
that 9-1-1 call does not
show up in your call log.
There's a good reason for this.
In a lot of cases-- such as
domestic violence situations--
it's actually very
important that there
is no evidence on the
phone that somebody
has had to contact
emergency services,
that the users as
privacy is preserved.
So instead, we
switched to data SMS.
This is simply a subset of
the normal SMS standard that
allows for binary payloads.
But more importantly, does not
show up in the user's outbox
and helps us preserve
the user's privacy.
A couple other things
I want to mention.
SMS generally functions better
in lower signal coverage.
It doesn't require a data
connection, of course.
This makes it very useful
to us in emerging markets.
It may require some coordination
with carriers, of course.
So let's contrast
SMS with HTTPS, now.
The first, and most
important, difference for us,
is just HTTPS can handle
much more information.
It's not size limited
like an SMS is.
It's a very flexible and
more importantly, extensible.
So you can add new information.
Add new key value pairs
to help give our partners
more information.
And help save lives that way.
Now, we found that when a high
quality data collection is
present, HTTPS
actually turns out
to be more reliable
than SMS, generally.
Of course, this depends
on your cell environment.
Your signal environment.
The country you're in.
A whole bunch of things.
But overall, we see
HTTPS is the way forward,
but were unwilling to leave
out incumbent markets.
So we encourage our
partners to use both options
whenever possible.
So now that we have a high
level understanding of how
we transmit location, the
next piece of the puzzle
is how we actually figure
out where the phone is
in the first place.
So to tell you a little
bit about the Android Fused
Location provider, here's Steve.
STEVE MALKOS: Great.
Thanks, Soonil.
Hello, everyone.
My name's Steve Markos, and
I also helped co-found ELS.
I'm super excited to be
here with you all today.
Now, let's talk about
how location is computed.
Because getting an
accurate location
is the key to all of this.
The faster and more
accurate location
we can deliver, the
more people we can help.
Accuracy and speed of location
will reduce the emergency
response times.
Here's a great quote
from the US government,
the FCC estimates
that 10,000 lives
could be saved every year--
for one minute sooner, if a
user was calling the emergency
dispatching center.
That's a very
powerful statement.
One minute sooner, having
the potential to save 10,000
additional lives every year?
It's quite powerful.
OK, so what you saw
earlier, from Soonil,
was that the existing
emergency system today,
either used a cell-based
position or GPS-based position.
Let's first focus on cell.
Cell tower positions--
to emergency responders--
are not considered a location
that they could dispatch help
to.
That's because the
emergency operator
is seeing the civic address
to the nearest cell tower.
And that's nowhere near
where the actual emergency
is taking place.
And cell tower position ranges
in the thousands of feet,
or hundreds of meters.
Like, in this
example, where we see
the cell tower
position at our office
is over 2000 feet,
or 600 meters.
GPS.
Everyone in this room
is pretty much aware
that GPS works great
when we're outdoors,
in the open sky environment.
Like in this
example where we see
GPS Position fix of about
25 meters, or 85 feet.
This was taken indoors and it's
not that good of a position.
GPS doesn't work
that well indoors.
This is the true
location where we
were when we did this example.
But when you're outside, in
a pure open sky environment,
GPS is typically around five to
six meters, or nine to 10 feet.
There are many issues with
getting GPS into the legacy
emergency dispatching system.
I'm going to highlight
two of those today.
The first issue is that when
the GPS position is computed,
it's actually computed
on the carrier's network.
It's not the location
that's available
on your mobile device,
which is much more accurate.
The second issue is
that the carrier is only
computing a single GPS
position fix, whereas ELS
can compute multiple fixes
throughout the entire duration
of that call.
So, more or less,
GPS has you covered
for the most part,
when you're outdoors,
in an open sky environment.
But what about a downtown,
dense, deep urban area?
Or when you're indoors,
or deep indoors?
That's where we can help with
our comprehensive positioning
solution, which includes
indoor and outdoor locations.
We call it the Fused
Location provider, or FLP.
The Fused Location provider
is comprised of Wi-Fi, GPS,
and sensors to do
sensor fusion that gets
us this very accurate location.
And the Fused
Location provider is
available on almost every
Android handset in the market
today.
In this example, the FLP is
able to compute a very accurate
position indoors.
Right here, we
produced a position
at about 29 feet,
or nine meters.
Earlier today, there was a
talk at Google I/O called
Seamless and Smooth Location
Everywhere With the New Fused
Location Provider.
If you didn't get a
chance to see it live,
watch it on YouTube.
OK, so this is the flow from
the lower hardware to the Fused
Location provider.
It looks something like this.
There's many different
location providers in Android.
Let's say, as an app developer--
which most of you are in this
room--
wanted to create an app that
only access GPS only locations.
You could do that by
calling the location
Manager APIs in Android.
Or let's say you wanted
to build an app that
only access Wi-Fi locations,
or cell-based locations.
Then, you could call the NLP, or
the Network Location Provider.
But if you simply
wanted to get the best
of what Google offers--
which uses all the different
location providers,
along with the sensors
doing sensor fusion--
our recommendation is to
access the FLP directly.
The Fused Location provider
fuses all these technologies
together in order to derive
the best possible location.
And that's what we supply
to the emergency responders.
So the FLP is ubiquitous.
It works globally, by
providing 3D locations
in all different
types of environments.
We're especially proud
of launching altitude,
or 3D location, for indoors.
So now, we provide 3D
x, y, and z locations,
not only for outdoor
environments, but also indoors.
The FLP is fast.
GPS can sometimes
take a very long time
to get a position fix.
The FLP is almost
instant on, and gives you
very quick location
updates as you move around.
This is important--
as we noted earlier--
because the sooner help
is sent, the better.
And the FLP is accurate.
According to the EPA, the
Environmental Protection
Agency, the average American
spends 87% of their time
indoors.
This is including while
they sleep, as well.
So the FLP needs to work.
And it needs to work
accurately, especially when
we need it most, while indoors.
OK, demo time.
As we were planning this
demo for Google I/O,
we said we wanted to do a demo
that people could relate to.
So we went to one of the
most recognizable places
that we could think of.
I could hear Sean
Connery's voice, right now,
from the movie The Rock.
OK, let me try this on you.
[IMITATING SEAN CONNERY]
Welcome to the rock.
[NORMAL VOICE] Or otherwise
known as Alcatraz Island.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
But Alcatraz has its
own set of challenges.
It has lots of metal.
Super thick, concrete walls.
And tiny, tiny windows.
This is not conducive for
good GPS or Wi-Fi signaling
conditions when computing
our Fused Location provider
positions.
But we said, we'd
like challenges,
let's see how well we'll do.
So we worked with the San
Francisco Emergency Dispatching
Center, who allowed us to place
real calls into their center.
What this demo will show us is
the voice from the call taker
will be receiving
locations nowhere
near the actual emergency
where that's taking place.
But I'd like you
to pay attention
to how quickly the location
shows up on the phone.
And how quickly the
location shows up
on the laptop with
the red blinking dot.
That's very accurate
update from ELS,
even before the
call is connected.
Let's play the clip
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- 9-1-1 emergency,
what are you reporting?
- Hi, this is a test
call from Google.
I was reaching out
to see if I can
get the address on your screen.
- Hold on.
610 Old Mason.
- Can you repeat
that one more time?
- 610 Old Mason.
- Perfect.
Can I also get the
latitude and longitude?
- Latitude, 37.80431400.
A longitude of
negative 122.451328.
- Perfect.
Thank you very much.
- OK, you're welcome.
[CALL DISCONNECTED]
[END PLAYBACK]
STEVE MALKOS: What we saw from
the Legacy Emergency System
is unfortunately, very common.
The dispatch operator noted
a latitude and longitude,
which mapped to the
nearest cell tower address.
Both these locations
were to over 2.5 miles
away from the actual emergency.
But what we saw with the ELS is
the location shown here in red
was right on top of
the true location.
And it could have also, been
available to the emergency
responder even before
that call was answered.
We're really excited about
this service and its potential
to help more and
more people globally.
Next up, you'll
hear from Fiona, who
will talk to us about
some of the challenges
around launching ELS globally.
FIONA LEE: Thanks, Steve.
So, Soonil, Steve, and
Maria have described
how we engineered ELS.
And I think we've shown
you that ELS provides
more accurate location faster
than Legacy E911 Location
Solutions.
But just because you
build a better technology,
does not mean that people
are actually going to use it.
So I'm going to talk to you
about how we launched MLS
around the world.
And I'm going to focus on the
non-technical factors that
played a key role in our
ability to successfully deploy
ELS on a global scale.
Now, don't get me
wrong, we didn't have
all the answers on day one.
But we listened to our users.
We learned.
And we iterated over time.
So the first factor to keep
in mind is the ecosystem.
What are the characteristics
of the community
of people who will use
your product or service?
What's the environment
in which they operate?
What products do they
currently use today?
With ELS, we focused on
two sets target users.
The public safety professional.
And the end user, who will
just dial or text in emergency
number and expect it to work.
So when we looked at the
public safety ecosystem,
the first thing that
jumped out at us
is that it is disparate
and fragmented.
So you have some countries with
just a handful of emergency
communication centers.
And then you have the
US, with over 6,500.
That's more than all the
emergency communication
centers in Europe.
There are some
emergency centers that
are only staffed by two people.
And then there
are some that have
hundreds, or thousands, of
people taking emergency calls.
They all use
different IT systems.
In the US we have one
emergency number, 9-1-1.
Thailand has 50.
So what that told
us was that we have
to build ELS to be very
flexible, and to offer options.
And Soonil walked you through
all the different configuration
options that we provide.
Second thing about
public safety is
that it is rife with
legacy infrastructure.
This tends to be expensive.
Proprietary.
Have high upgrade costs.
And high switching costs.
So what we did, was we built yes
so it's standards based, right?
So data SMS adheres to the
advanced mobile location
specification.
And HTTPS is HTTPS.
The benefit of
adhering to standards
is that it makes it very easy
for your partners to deploy.
There's a uniform
process to deploy.
We also design each ELS
to be fast and easy.
So we can turn on a
new configuration.
We can change configurations.
And we can roll that all
out in under 24 hours.
Finally, we designed
ELS to be safe.
When we decide on a
production rollout,
we work with our partners
to roll ELS out in phases.
We usually start at 1%.
We let that soak for a few days.
Then we increase to 5%.
Soak some more.
And we increase in increments.
And at any point in time, it
is really easy to roll back.
The third factor to keep
in mind is public safety
is risk averse, right?
So lives on the line.
The costs of making a
mistake are very, very high.
So we built ELS, as
I said, to be safe.
And to roll in phases.
The second factor
to keep in mind
is your distribution,
or business model.
How do you plan on
getting your product
into the hands of users?
As developers, it's
really important for you
to find a distribution model
that can scale rapidly.
For us, we made ELS free.
Free to partners.
Free to public safety.
Mostly, because it is
the right thing to do,
and we want to keep
Android users safe.
But free is good.
Free promotes adoption.
And public safety likes
free, because they
tend to be budget constrained.
Second key decision we
made was to distribute
ELS via Google Play services.
This gave us a scalable
distribution mechanism.
And it allowed ELS to be
ubiquitously available.
Because Google Play services
ships with just about every
approved Android phone.
The other nice thing about going
out with Google Play services
is that Google Play
services updates over weeks.
That meant we could roll out
ELS updates quickly, and not
be tied to an annual
OS release cycle.
And then, finally, we
built ELS to be user first.
For the user who
cares about privacy,
we offer an opt out feature.
And, as my colleagues have
said, we calculate location
on the device.
And we only activate ELS when
an emergency call is made.
Now, there were trade
offs in this, right?
Because you can offer much
more functionality when you do
service side processing.
But we made a decision
not to do that.
The other thing
about ELS is the user
doesn't have to take any action.
No special hardware
required on the phone.
No need to download an app.
If ELS is deployed
in your region,
you just dial and text
the emergency number
and it will work.
For the public
safety professional,
we designed ELS so that ELS can
be easily integrated into one
of their existing systems.
So I don't know if you've ever
seen an emergency call taker.
But they are juggling about
five different screens
on their desk.
And the last thing
we want to do is
force them to have a
sixth screen, in order
to get ELS location data.
So one of our best practice
recommendations to partners
is integrate ELS location
data into one of the existing
systems currently used at
the emergency communications
center.
Usually, their mapping
system, or their computer
aided dispatch system.
Finally, ELS is future friendly.
We have built it so that it
will be easily integrated
into next generation public
safety systems that are being
designed all over the world.
This third factor is my
personal favorite, regulation.
What are the laws pertaining
to your product and service?
Who makes those Laws?
And how explicit
is the language?
So, as you might
expect, there is
a lot of regulation
surrounding public safety.
It's a mission critical service.
And governments want
to keep people safe.
And for ELS, there's an
additional implication for us.
Because we transmit location
during an emergency call,
there are privacy
implications, as well.
So when we look at regulation,
the first thing we notice
is that laws are lagging.
Regulators simply cannot
keep pace with technology.
So we position ELS as
a supplemental service.
It's not meant to replace
existing emergency location
solutions.
It's meant to augment it, and
provide the 9-1-1, or emergency
call taker, with another
tool in their toolkit.
Second thing about law is--
believe it or not--
it can be ambiguous.
Especially, laws that pertain
to privacy with respect
to emerging new technologies.
So when we looked
at some countries,
we found that there were no
explicit laws saying that you
cannot transmit location
during an emergency.
But there were no laws that
explicitly said, you can,
as well.
So this is a gray area.
And we chose to exercise
due diligence and caution.
And we decided to calculate
location on the device,
and then transmit it
directly to our partners,
so that no personally
identifiable information is
stored on Google servers.
Finally, laws are complex.
There are different regulatory
frameworks and privacy laws
in each country.
These laws, believe it or not,
can be sometimes contradictory.
Often overlapping.
And in the case
of ELS, generally,
multi-jurisdictional.
Because you make
an emergency call
over the
telecommunications network,
or you send an emergency text
over the telecommunications
network, we had to deal with the
Ministry of Telecommunications.
We also had to deal with
the Ministry of Interior,
which is generally,
responsible for public safety.
Sometimes the
Ministry of Defense.
And the Ministry of Health.
And then there were also
data protection agencies
that we had to keep in mind.
Last, but not least,
is partnerships.
So good partners are bridges.
We view our partners as a
scaling force multiplier.
And this is particularly
true in public safety,
because public safety
tends not to be
an early adopter of technology.
So we rely on our partners
to educate and train
public safety.
And also to work with them to
operationalize ELS location
data.
So it can be useful in the
emergency communications
center.
So what we do is we
look for partners that
have really high standards.
In quality assurance.
In security.
In monitoring.
In reporting.
And in operational support.
This ensures that we
have a high quality
end to end deployment of ELS.
So how are we doing today?
Today, ELS is live
in 18 countries,
serving a population of
600 plus million users.
And we send location for over 1
and 1/2 million emergency calls
per day.
One of the nice things
about being on the ELS team
is learning about
how ELS has made
a difference in emergencies
around the world.
So I'd like to share a
couple of stories with you.
The first one has to do with a
medical emergency in Lithuania.
8-year-old boy calls
emergency services.
He's found his father
unconscious, maybe dead.
He doesn't know
his home address.
He doesn't know the phone number
of any of his family members.
Now, remember,
Lithuania public safety
does not get location
by a GPS, only cell.
So the call taker is
seeing a cell tower
location of a whopping 14
kilometers, almost nine miles.
In a densely populated
neighborhood,
that's hundreds, if not
thousands, of houses
that you have to search.
But thanks to ELS, which
pinpointed the exact house
where the boy made the call--
accuracy rate is of 6 meters--
the first responders
could be dispatched
to render medical
help really quickly.
And as it turns out,
the man was suffering
from an epileptic seizure.
Second instance is a serious
mountain biking accident
in Austria.
Mountain biker was alone.
Had a bad accident in
a deeply forested area.
No landmarks.
No addresses.
Cell tower location
was 900 plus meters.
But thanks to ELS, which gave
a 12 meter accuracy radius,
they could send medical
help to the injured biker--
to take him to the hospital--
because they could locate him
quickly.
So I'd like to hand the
microphone back to Maria
to wrap up.
MARIA GARCIA PUYOL:
Thanks, Fiona.
So now that you've learned more
about how the Android Emergency
Location Service works, I'd
like to close this session
with some final thoughts.
Thanks to ELS,
your Android phone
is able to send accurate
location in 18 countries,
during emergencies
to first responders.
But for us, this is
just the beginning.
We're working on deploying
the Android Emergency Location
Service in more countries,
because we'd like to help
as many people as possible.
Also, even though
our location accuracy
is much better than the
existing legacy location
systems in emergency
services, we're
always working on
improving location.
Both indoors and outdoors.
And one of our very
next challenging goals--
and we like challenges-- is to
provide dispatchable addresses.
And also, floor numbers
to first responders,
so that they can find you
when you dial an emergency
number even faster.
I, for one, am very
proud of the impact
ELS has had on people's lives.
And I'm very happy
to know that if I
were to dial 9-1-1 today,
because I found a person
standing in the
middle of the highway,
first responders would be able
to locate me right away here,
in Mountain View.
This project, of course,
wouldn't have been possible
without the help of our many
partners and collaborators
around the world.
So we want to give
them a special thanks.
And also, thank
you all very much
for coming to Google I/O. And
for coming to our session.
Please reach out if
you have any questions,
or want to know more.
That's all from us, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]